[Applause]
all right
you like that
yes am I sitting here yes you are
sitting there oh my goodness you just
seem like such a cool person I really
yes and the more layers I peel back
about you you just seem like such a good
cool fun rad person
you're very sweet you're very sweet just
don't peel back any more layers
but listen I'm I'm okay I okay first of
all we were talking in the news really
quickly about Jennifer Coolidge yeah I I
I'll just get straight to the point I
think she was staring at Lenny's
everything he's a very handsome man I
mean
is he free is he does he he seems like
he would just walk around naked without
like an issue you know I was mostly in
concerned about what Lenny was going to
be like because to me he is such a rock
star yeah and Lenny literally he truly I
mean he's an incredibly nice dude is it
true Jennifer Lopez yeah Jennifer
Coolidge
Lenny Kravitz they like stayed in a
house together well no no this is the
way it went it went okay it was Cheech
Jennifer Desmond Cali Darcy uh uh Sonya
Braga although the whole cast they put
me in a house and they put Jen in her
own house okay so I didn't get to hang
out they had like a dorm situation going
on like a beautiful dorm like the most
beautiful dorm you've ever seen and you
went there trying dinners
play music
yeah and I got I had to sit home by
myself but I think they're probably
smart to leave us you know to leave me
and I would have just had to they were
like you two need your beauty sleep yeah
it was it was truly one of the most
but uh
gratifying experiences I've ever had on
a movie everything about it was one of
my best experiences I'm safe and I
and I'm off because everybody's talking
about the movie there are 23 rom-coms
being made this year really all the time
we can do one one time
[Applause]
okay I want to be on one of your
vacations with your buddies you sent in
a video I'm so in love with this
vacation or this moment is it true
there's ice and a sauna that's my setup
what do you guys do well it's not really
a vacation it's kind of my I have a
cabin I spend half my time out in the
woods deep in the woods another reason I
love you I truly it's my happy place and
one of the things we do
in the winter is you know snowmobile and
ice fish and Ice plunge so what what's
happened over the last couple of years
is people around the lake know about it
it's become like this tradition to bring
in the New Year people jump in that that
ice hole and I have a a wood burning
sauna right next to it so you get in
there first then you get nice and then
you get back in the sauna it's
it really is oh
speaking of a beautiful way to put
things will you tell me about the
proposal that you did which is I just
again where does it end well this was I
mean I wish I could say that I'm usually
this romantic but this was a I was this
was one of my best okay I was I'm really
proud of this one so one morning I was
sitting there I was like okay tonight's
the night I think I got to do it tonight
I got to do it tonight and and I thought
okay we're gonna do there's a beautiful
little Sandbar at Little Palm Island is
where we stayed and I had this idea to
do this like what if I put like a
message in a bottle that rolled up
and I went up to the concierge asked if
they had a old wine bottle they did took
some stationery from the hotel burned
the edges I had it all timed out with
the concierge so that
we're going to be out at 5 15 for dinner
I need you to go put it like 5 14. have
the bottle in there so we can walk out
it's just rolling up to the thing and
that's when she found the bottle and
that's when I asked her to marry me and
it worked
all right so let's add this layer and
you are also uh you make a mean lasagna
apparently
I make two things I make really good
ribs and I make really good lasagna and
lasagna was literally out of necessity
from college I was gonna say you learned
to do it in college like my it's it's
not a fancy recipe at all but but it's
so good to us I'll gladly teach it
[Music]